ciao ragazzi allora il video che state
per vedere e sullo speciale 45 mila
iscritti grazie mille un numero assurdo
è un video particolare che hanno già
fatto altri youtubers è che mi avete
veramente chiesto in tantissimi di fare
io ci tenevo particolarmente a farlo
ed è su glo mylife praticamente consiste
nel disegnare la propria vita e quindi
niente spero che vi piaccia eletto
questo vi lascio al video è che dire vi
presento fa vj è la tutti ragazzi io
sono fa vj e oggi siamo sud my life
tutto iniziò a 18 anni fa quando mia
madre mi diede alla luce
ok pessima robot la nascita i miei
genitori decisero di chiamarmi lorenzo
nei primi anni della mia vita abbiamo
vissuto in un piccolo appartamento a
torino ma quando compì tre anni i miei
genitori decisero di trasferirsi in un
piccolo paesino sperduto tra i campi in
periferia
più o meno come heidi diciamo aspettate
un attimo e questa sarebbe heidi
crescendo mi sono sempre trovato bene
soltanto che tutti i miei vicini di casa
avevano figlie femmine quindi mi
ritrovai spesso a giocare da solo e ben
presto grazie a questo motivo con obi il
mondo dei videogames sacchetto e non la
mentalità dei bambini ragazze videogames
ovviamente videogames mio padre si
divertiva spesso a giocare i videogames
di un bel giorno all'età di cinque anni
decisi di prendere il controllo della
situazione cancellandoli completamente
la memory card e della playstation 1 con
ogni salvataggio al suo interno e da
quel momento la playstation diventò mia
è il mio primo gioco in assoluto full
metal gear solid che attualmente rimane
il mio videogame preferiti in quanto
moltissimi ricordi legati ad esso ma in
generale ho moltissimi ricordi legati
videogames nella mia infanzia a scuola
sono sempre stato un ragazzo parecchio
introverso sempre selezionato le mie
amicizie non sono mai andato oltre
quelle la passione che avevo da
piccolino la più grande è sempre stata
quella di collezionare carte e figurine
di ogni tipo da pokémon a yu gi oh due
master dragon ball comprando tonnellate
e tonnellate di figurine da piccolo cero
affezionatissimo ei non vi è già andato
a tocca legno goku con il tempo
crescendo le abitudini cambia
quando ma una passione mi è sempre
rimasta ancora videogames una volta
finite le medie scelsi informatica come
indirizzo scolastico a torino
inizialmente mi aveva tirato per gli
aerei piazzati nel cortile ma comunque
scelsi questa scuola perché sin da
piccolo mi avevano sempre detto che era
un genio dell'informatica dato che è mio
padre quando aveva problemi al pci mi
chiedeva spesso a me per risolvere i
suoi problemi anche se avevo 10 anni per
l'appunto iscrivendomi a questa scuola
ho sempre avuto voti altissimi in
informatica
infatti ora come ora o quattro una volta
iniziata la squadra il mio carattere non
era cambiato sono sempre stato il solito
a selezionarsi le amicizie ei miei due
migliori amici con i quali feci
conoscenza furono nicolas e luca anche
loro con la passione per i videogames
dopo tre anni passati a divertirci
ridere scherzare insieme abbiamo deciso
per gioco di provare a far video su
youtube così fondammo il di share e di
gaming composto da me nichi box e ai
puffo il canale ebbe subito un discreto
successo e dopo un anno raggiungiamo il
traguardo incredibile di 10.000 iscritti
nell'estate 2012 nicolas e luca andarono
in vacanza insieme per due settimane
lasciandovi completamente solo e
abbandonato
[Musica]
ti stai commuovendo così in quel periodo
di tempo dovetti registrare da solo per
il canale è così deciso di dar vita una
serie horror intitolata giochi nel buio
nella quale andava a giocare videogames
indiehorror la serie ebbe un successo
clamoroso specialmente nel video this
lander essendo stato il primo in italia
a farlo è così al ritorno di ai buffoni
chi box il canale era ormai in pieno di
utenti ai quali interessava soltanto
vedere i video della mia rubrica è così
all'inizio del 2013 decise di aprire un
mio canale inizialmente non trovavo il
nome giusto ma dopo parecchie parecchi
tentativi decisi di chiamarlo fa deejay
tv è così inizia a far video per conto
mio principalmente i video che faceva
non incentrati sulla horror ma con il
tempo mi espansi anche sul lato comico
dando vita serie come happy uil su
motori cat mario cat mari occhi il
canale credo ad una velocità
inimmaginabile ricevendo sempre ottimi
feedback e parecchi commenti positivi da
parte vostra ed in soli quattro mesi
raggiunsi un traguardo che non mi sarei
mai potuto immaginare ovvero 45 mila
iscritti e quindi ragazzi questo è stato
il mio percorso fino ad oggi un percorso
veramente stupendo perché ogni giorno
registrare video mi permette di vist
rami dalla vita di tutti i giorni e di
farmi parecchie risate con voi quindi
ragazzi grazie per tutti mi piace perché
condividete i miei video su facebook è
per tutti gli studenti di commenti che
mi lasciate perché davvero ragazzi inv
incoraggiate a dare sempre del mio
meglio quindi veramente ragazzi grazie
non smetterò mai di portare avanti
questa mia passione è grazie ragazzi per
aver reso possibile tutto questo
vi voglio veramente bene
[Musica]
è così ragazzi la mia storia si conclude
qui come al solito lasciate un commento
mi piace condividetelo su facebook se
volete la mia pagina di facebook come in
ogni video la trovate nella descrizione
se non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi
e noi ci vediamo al prossimo video bella
ragazzi